it's the project for Rosa hello my name
is Hank green and I along with my
brother John green with the help of all
of YouTube and some very awesome people
in particular have organized the project
for awesome of which this video is a
tiny tiny part basically if you've been
hiding under a rock the project for
awesome is attained which youtubers get
the opportunity to talk about their
favorite charities encourage people to
donate to those charities and you know
have a good time but also talk about
people who are doing good things and
then a cadre of about 10,000 people are
going to roam across YouTube and promote
these videos of various ways so that
they become the most viewed most
discussed most talked-about most
important videos on YouTube for at least
two days and then you know maybe the
next day the world is a slightly better
place that's the hope anyway that's part
of the project for awesome yesterday
afternoon I called my brother up and I
told him to do two things one put a CD
in the microwave for 5 seconds to get
some steel wool and touch a 9-volt
battery to it this my friends is the
result one regulation microwave one CD
Bridge to Terabithia soundtrack don't
know how I got it not sorry to be
parting with it nothing personal Miley
Cyrus go
I panicked turn off the camera
aha science smells horrible Hank I'm
standing here in my kitchen with steel
wool and one regulation 9-volt battery
how does it work Hank is there a fire
inside the battery and how do they get
the steel wool does it involve steel
sheep I don't know the answer to these
questions due to poor scientific
education it's true John Green doesn't
understand science and it's not because
he's not a smart guy it's not because he
can't understand that the steel wool is
short-circuiting the battery it's
because science education in this
country sucks
only about 17% of American adults are
scientifically literate and that doesn't
give me a lot of Hope in our democracies
ability to make the correct decisions
when it comes to scientific legislation
and just in general I think that the
people of the world should know more
about science but the question is how
can you and I make a difference how can
we promote scientific illiteracy among
today's young people so that tomorrow's
old people will know what the frick
they're talking about well that's where
donorschoose.org comes in this is an
amazing sight it's really cool basically
if you're a teacher you just submit a
little proposal you say what you want
money for and that if people think that
that's a good idea like if that's a good
lesson plan if people agree that that's
something that the kids need then they
give you money and the kids get the
stuff they need so not only does it let
you and me help out kids who need better
education but it also encourages
teachers to think of good ways to use
our money because we're not gonna give
him our money and left the idea sounds
like a good idea for example the teacher
wants to buy 30 copies of Jurassic Park
because she wants to get the kids
excited about genetics some people might
say that Michael dragon was an idiot and
that entire book is a scientific
travesty while others might think that
that's a really good way to get kids
excited about science it's up to you
it's up to you to decide whether or not
these teachers are having good ideas and
I've been going through donorschoose.org
for like half the day trying to find
really inspired science teachers who
really need resources that they
otherwise couldn't get personally I have
really good science teachers and fairly
good scientific equipment so I feel
obligated to try and make sure that
other students get the same
opportunities that I did sometimes you
read these teachers stories and it is
just despicable yeah I mean you have to
give them money and if you give them
more than $100 the kids will give you a
thank-you card they'll all sign it and
say thank you God
right now the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation is running a special and a
bunch of the projects will be met with
matched donations so it only costs 50%
as much to do 100% of the good thanks
bill DonorsChoose has won all kinds of
awards and it is a great place to be
spending your charity time and money so
thank you the donorschoose.org and thank
you to everyone who's watching this
please go to donorschoose.org and search
through and consider finding a classroom
that you can really really help that it
doesn't even have to be science it can
be anything and you can help and of
course Thank You doll the other amazing
people participated and brought you four
awesome John and I will be live on
blogtv all freaking days link in the
sidebar
and we will be doing project for all
soapy things so we will see you there I
can't tell you how much I appreciate all
of you working so hard to make this
project a success thank you for the
awesome